are you about to start work on a data
science project
not so fast because there's a fairly
good chance that that project you're
working on
is going to fail now why is that keep
watching and we'll discuss why that is
i'm richard and this is richard on data
so a lot of different companies have
weighed in on this issue
and they all seem to be coming to the
same pessimistic conclusion
and if that wasn't bad enough their
outlooks seem to be getting
worse every single year let's read this
from bottom to top
so in may 2017 cisco reported that iot
initiatives have a
74 failure rate then around the same
time as that
gartner predicted that 60 of big data
projects
would fail to move past preliminary
stages only to correct that a little bit
later and say
actually the real number is closer to 85
percent of big data projects we're going
to fail
a year later they came out and they said
80 percent of analytics insights will
not deliver business outcomes through
2022 and that 80 percent of ai projects
would remain alchemy run by wizards
quote unquote through 2020
then you have new vantage claiming that
77
of businesses report that big data and
ai initiatives never got business
adoption
only they got then massively one-upped
by venturebeat ai
who report that 87 of data science
projects
never actually make it into production
so i'm going to detail
why exactly this seems to be the case
but i also want to point out that
i've been there a few years ago i was
involved in a project to predict the
onset of a particular medical condition
and everything was going great it was a
successful project
or at least it seemed to be until
basically it just became relegated to
some powerpoint slides
then there was another large product i
worked on in which i was one of the lead
data scientists
and there's a lot of really cool novel
statistical and simulation models in it
but it never actually made it into
production so believe me when i say
i can relate to all of this so i'm gonna
go through
five often cited reasons for why data
science projects seem to fail so often
and when possible i'm gonna bring up how
these things actually manifested in my
own projects
before i do that just a few things to
ask of you guys
number one subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already and hit the
notification bell so youtube notifies
you whenever i upload a video
then take just one second of your time
to smash the like button because that
really does help my content reach a
larger audience
also in the description of this video i
will have a link to my patreon account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me in that way it would be
enormously appreciated
so let's start with what can potentially
be the biggest issue of them all
and that's not solving the right problem
and there's a saying that for some
people
they will build models in search of a
problem and that's particularly true of
people who are just
fresh getting out of school and they're
looking for opportunities to grow their
technical capabilities
well the problem is true value is never
actually going to be created that way
you may think that something you created
is amazing
but unless it's solving a very concrete
problem for somebody else
at the end of the day nobody is really
gonna care
now that's a very specific and extreme
example of this broader issue
but you'd be surprised how often this
sort of thing can occur
every single data science problem begins
with
one critical and fundamental question
and that is what is the purpose of this
analysis
or project or whatever you want to call
it it's from
this point that literally everything you
do
is downstream you need to know exactly
what problem you're trying to solve
before you can begin thinking about what
solution you can build
what data you need what assumptions need
to be made the list goes on and on
suppose you have a client that comes to
you and they say they need a staffing or
a scheduling algorithm
well before you can even begin to think
about how you can make their life
easier you need to understand what it is
they're doing
right now and why that isn't working
and it takes domain expertise and
communication skills to get to that
point
you may eventually find out that they
don't actually need a scheduling or
staffing algorithm or anything like that
but the true solution is something
that's much simpler
than if you're really good you can make
them think that that sort of thing was
their idea
all along but that's a consulting jedi
mind trick for another day
next issue is related to the first one
but it's a little bit more specific
and it's when you lack support from key
stakeholders
this is another one that illustrates the
importance of communication in data
science
because at the end of the day you are
creating solutions
for other human beings and those
solutions should be things
other people understand and that they
can actually use
well suppose your most important
stakeholders don't trust or don't
understand whatever it is that you're
giving them
or telling them to use well you don't
stand a chance then
now i have a couple personal examples
for this one which will hopefully help
to illustrate it a bit
one simpler example i was on this
project where we were presenting this
report to a department head
and one of the findings from that report
was that his staff were only doing
value ad activities 40 percent of the
time
well let's just say that didn't exactly
make him look good
and he didn't exactly receive it very
well in the project i described where we
were building a model to predict the
onset of a medical condition
there was one of the medical directors
who was extremely skeptical about the
whole endeavor
now he was thinking okay so i have 20
plus years of medical experience
how is some model gonna come around and
tell me what to do and know
better than i do now he was thinking
that and you got to think from his
perspective
he's totally within his rights and
reason to think that
now if this issue happens to you you may
or may not be working on the right
problem
but either way this is something that
you need to get resolved
if you want to have any chance of your
solution getting adopted
third item on this list is when you
build something that
fails to integrate with clients systems
and technology
or processes let me start this one off
by saying that
change is disruptive and a lot of people
really don't like it
and that's part of why the second item
about stakeholder support is so
important
let's go back to my example about
building a model to predict the onset of
some medical condition
and let's just say hypothetically that
model was built
and it comes back with a specific
prediction for somebody that
yes that patient is about to develop
rapid clinical deterioration
now if you think about it that model
would have to be somewhere where it can
interface with data in real time
and then that result would have to be
communicated to the right people
those people then have to use that
information to take
some kind of medical action with it you
see now that there's a lot of moving
parts to something like this
you have a systems integration component
and you have channels of communication
for the organization
through which information needs to move
researcher david becker broke down the
leading causes in big data project
failures in a 2017
research paper now he does this in a
very granular fashion
but some of these things include data
integration
technology complexity management and
cultural resistance
technology architecture and
infrastructure technology change
all of that so you see this is really
something that requires a
multi-disciplinary approach
and upfront planning now for number four
let me start this one off by saying that
anybody who's worked in data science for
a while will tell you
poor data quality is the rule rather
than the exception
now that's fine that's no problem until
you fail to plan for it
i just did a video on exactly how bad
data quality can affect any kind of
modeling effort you do
if you haven't seen that video yet
highly recommend it i'll have a card up
above as well as a link in the
description
but in short you're going to run into
problems like low sample size
bad amount of variation useless and
uninformative variables
all these sorts of things which are
going to impair your results unless you
address these issues
so there should be no question that bad
data
or at least some kind of data related
problems in general
are just baked into the equation you
need to know that that's going to happen
and just plan and adjust for it
accordingly oftentimes you're going to
have these
data issues you need to resolve them and
that can take a lot longer than you
would first expect it to
also honestly most of the time you're
probably
not going to be able to get more data so
you have to work with what you're given
and really practically understand how
problems like
low sample size assumptions data
problems
all that good stuff truly impacts what
you deliver
what you deliver is never going to be
perfect
but if you understand what problems you
have you plan for them and you deal with
them accordingly
you should be able to come up with a
solution that's good and gets the job
done
then the last item to talk about here is
having the wrong expertise on board
so first of all you need to have a
multi-disciplinary approach to any data
science project
now unless the domain expertise of the
data scientists is stellar
somebody's got to be around who can
provide subject matter expertise
then you need some project management up
top and you need the
right amount of data science expertise
let's look at a couple extremes
if you don't have any data scientists on
deck who are asking the right questions
you're going to get steamrolled because
things like bias
simpson's paradox correlation versus
causation
the regression effect all these things
manifest in data analyses
and if you're not asking the right
questions you have opportunity on top of
opportunity to make mistakes
but the opposite extreme is possible too
so in one project i was working on in
the past
we had about eight people who were
involved in the project on and off
and five of those people were machine
learning and modeling experts
and not only did nobody have any work to
do for about the whole
first half of the project but the whole
thing was just a disorganized complete
mess
you can't be working in silos you need
to be working in a cross-functional
capacity
but you also can't get the idea that you
can just throw a whole bunch of really
smart people at a problem
and then hope that something really good
is going to turn out on the other end
because it won't so hopefully now the
fact that so many data science projects
fail makes sense to you and if you're
somebody who's just now coming out of
college
you now know exactly what you're walking
into lots of people get out of college
and they think that they know
everything that there is to know well if
that was true
then the failure rate in real projects
wouldn't be so high now would it
now i don't want this to all sound too
discouraging ideally maybe even you're
working on a data science project right
now and you watch this whole video
and you had an aha moment that will help
you save your project from
an untimely failure at the end of the
day you have to continually practice
data science in the real world and do it
in an
unsiloed fashion then and only then can
you utilize data to achieve great things
in the world
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it or found it helpful
please consider sharing it also once
again smash the like button
and leave me a comment down below and
let me know if you've been involved in a
project
that's failed then i'll see you all in
the not so distant future
until then richard on data